my name is iris i come from greece and i  am an eu auditor  i work on both financial and performance  audits in the area of environment and  specifically in the area of fisheries  across all member states of the eu i  passed an epsom competition in 2013.  my name is yelena i'm latvian and i'm an  eu  auditor i carry out performance audits  in transport sector  which basically means that i travel  across the european union  and i visit transport infrastructure  projects in the member states  i am olivier i come from france and i am  an eu auditor  i owe the performance aspects of the  equation funds on agricultural programs  of the eu  you